- I'm here hanging out
with The Miz and Maryse.
Give it up, woo hoo!
(audience applauds and cheers)
Do you know how they say
everything's bigger in Texas?
If you don't then you're missing out
'cause we're awesome.
My next guest is living proof though.
She's an interior designer
who does everything
Texas size.
Valentine's Day, look at that tree,
the 4th of July,
Halloween, and of course, Christmas.
Though on most days you can
find her decorating Dallas
but today she's Skyping in to help us
with our own Christmas decor.
From Turtle Creek Lane let's
welcome Jennifer Houghton.
How you doing?
(audience applauds and cheers)
- It's so good to see you.
- It's good to see you again as well.
First of all, I love your outfit.
You're adorable.
But Jennifer, you went
with the Nutcracker theme
in your house this year, right?
So how early did you have to
get started to do all of that?
- So the minute Halloween goes
down, literally the next day,
November 1st, all of Halloween goes out
and Christmas starts to go up.
And yes you are right.
We are doing the Nutcracker theme
which means that every room
in the house is going
to be a different scene
from the Nutcracker ballet.
- Oh, that's so cool.
It's so creative.
Do you guys, do y'all go
all out for Christmas?
I know we were talking a little bit.
- This is my nightmare
right now, right now.
- And it's my favorite.
My favorite.
I love it by the way.
This is awesome.
- No, I completely disagree.
- I wanna tree
in every single room.
I love Christmas.
- Look, look, all right, first off.
Halloween ends and you don't
go straight to Christmas.
- Yes you do.
- There's Thanksgiving.
Like,
- It's the same thing.
- I had to go up in the attic.
I had to take all the
stuff down, build the tr-
I have cuts on my
fingers still to this day
from putting up Christmas stuff.
- Somebody bring out some tissue.
So Jennifer, explain what
you're showing us today.
- Okay, so y'all are going
to be building a mantle
and I know mantles can
be kind of intimidating
but they're really not
if you just break them
down into four easy steps.
I'm gonna teach you the steps.
- Okay.
- First of all, get your garland right.
Second, attach your ribbon correctly.
Third, pop in those hero
pieces that you've been dying
to pull out of the attic
and then fourth, sprinkle in some goodies
and you're done.
And Mike, since I know
you hate to decorate,
I did you a little favor.
I asked if we could have
your mantles almost completed
but you do gotta do a
little bit of work with me.
- That's done.
- That's not (laughs)
- That looks done to me.
(laughing)
I love that she said
and you get to go to the
attic, your favorite place.
- Oh, my favorite place.
(laughing)
- That's amazing, okay.
- So you're going to
take these hero pieces.
I like to do ones that give me some height
'cause on this mantle we're
doing like a mirrored image
the left and the right.
So just pop in those hero
pieces on either side over here.
- Okay.
- Oh yeah.
- You have that beautiful height.
- Mirror.
- All our hero pieces are in place.
(hands smacking)
- I gotta be honest with you.
I like that it's a mirror image
but I also liked how one was up top
and one was kind of down by the fire.
That was cool too.
- Yeah and you know what?
You can do mantles a
hundred different ways.
I just thought for Mike I'd
let him do it just simple.
- Yeah, I liked the, I liked the symmetry.
I'm into it.
- Simple is better.
(laughing)
- All right, well Jennifer,
now onto the finishing touches right?
- Okay, yes, this is where
we have a lot of fun.
This is where you go from
being amateur to a pro.
- I'm ready.
- Okay, what we're gonna
do is we're gonna add,
we're gonna sprinkle in our goodies.
I always love to add an
additional little swag
and it's super easy to do.
Add something there in the middle.
- Shoot.
- Attach it to another limb and wallah.
How fabulous is that?
(laughing)
- I'm gonna just like
- How're we doing?.
- Here, we gonna do this.
Hold on, I got it.
Hold on.
I'm gonna shove it up in there.
- You're doing great.
- Thank you.
- Yours looks like the
Christmas party after you,
had the night, the morning
after a Christmas party.
It's like those, where you
had a really good time.
I feel like my looks all right.
Like it looks, you know, I don't know.
And then I didn't have-
- I feel like you've done this before.
I feel like you've cheated
and like you've had
whole lessons and stuff.
- I love decorating
but I've never done that
but you know, can we
put the little house on?
Like all these little houses
and cars.
- Yes yes.
- Look at this.
- So now comes the really fun.
- Okay.
- Now you take your ornaments.
And what you always wanna do is start
with your biggest ornaments first
and just start placing those in.
And you're gonna go from the
biggest down to the smallest.
That's the trick
'cause then you get that
visual weight going on.
- Okay, oh.
- Add in those big pieces.
- Okay.
(ornaments crashing)
(laughing)
- Then we start with
that like medium size.
- And, last but not least right?
- And last but not least.
- Last but not least.
You gotta have the wrestling figure.
- You're not using any of your stuff.
- I did use my stuff.
- We're done.
(audience applauds)
- All right I think we've
done a fine job everybody.
We got it to work.
- Texas style.
(sleigh bells jingling)
- Wait, what?
It's that time again.
Release the snow.
Bring out the tree.
Let's get some (indistinct)
(holiday music)
(audience applauding and cheering)
Woo woo bah bah bah!
- Whoa ho.
- Oh yeah, feel it, feel it.
Feel that Christmas spirit. (laughs)
The Edible brand is
perfect for giving gifts
to all the people on your
holiday list, even Santa.
Their new Bakeshop line of treats
include miniature New
York style cheesecakes
and decadent brownies.
Plus there's something for everyone
with their traditional fruit arrangements
and flowers like the
chocolate dip ones, whatever.
To celebrate Edible is giving everyone
in our house seats a $200 gift card.
(audience applauds and cheers)
Thank you so much, Jennifer.